oh no here we go again brian keating
an allegedly serious scientist is having
on
another person to talk about god
god save us oh we're not gonna say that
but uh it is true i am having on dr
steven
c meyer author of darwin's doubt the
signature in the cell
and other uh expositions of so-called
intelligent design
and of course intelligent design tends
to get conflated with
creationism and young earth creationism
but actually nothing could really be
farther from the truth
stephen is a very highly scientifically
literate
i challenge you if you think that his
bonafides are not up to snuff
he has actually debated the most
imminent
atheist scientist in the world including
lawrence krauss and others
and i think you'll find him incredibly
introspective thoughtful person with a
very very good arguments
on his side for the case that he makes
in his new book
return of the god hypothesis which is
about
fine-tuning about entropy in the early
universe
about uh alexei valenkin
about lawrence krauss about richard
dawkins
about issues raised in his previous
books uh regarding the nature of
information
and the claim is simply defended here
not a personal god not jesus not moses
god of moses and or abraham but instead
the necessity in his claim
for a mind to create information and i
push back in many cases as you'll see
maybe you think i
succeeded in defending your viewpoint
whether that be
pro or against so-called intelligent
design
i hope you'll give it a chance if you
want to unsubscribe
i will refund your money which is zero
but i hope you don't i'm going to have
on
many many of the world's most eminent
scientists coming up including those
that use god just as much as steven does
namely michio kaku i also have on
david spurgle one of the most eminent
scientists in the world
and oh a guy by the name of john mather
is coming up very soon
he of course won the 2006 nobel prize in
physics
for his cosmological discoveries so i
urge you to
treat this with an open mind if you're
not interested i hope you won't
unsubscribe but i'll understand if you
do
but nevertheless you have to at least
give steven credit
and i hope i get a little credit too for
pushing the boundaries of what we know
about the origin of information itself
and stay tuned there'll be many many
more lectures including caleb scharf
who is a professor at columbia to my
knowledge secular
and he's going to talk about the rise of
information on his new book coming out
in may
we have many other guests coming up so
unsubscribe at your own loss at your own
peril
i hope you won't because i had a
phenomenal time talking with dr steven
meyer
and i hope you will enjoy this episode
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast and today
i am joined by a very interesting
individual someone i have spoken about
before uh on the podcast and in my day
job
as a practicing cosmologist
and and that is uh dr steven meyer who
is joining us he is
at the discovery institute and i will
give a proper introduction
to him uh as we go on but the
occasion of today's podcast interview
which is years in the making because
i've known of his work for many many
years
i've followed him and admired what he
does
and the role that he plays in the
philosophy of science and even
in as you'll find out intelligent design
what is this keating a respected
cosmologist is now
getting into intelligent design well
you'll find out
and uh as i said in the in comia
that i gave to this new book by our
wonderful guest today called the return
of the god hypothesis stephen c meyer
he's the author of the breakaway
bestselling book darwin's doubt
the signature in the cell many other
books
and works of a really outreach and
scientific communication
and it's such a treat to to be with you
today stephen and i'm so
i'm so enamored of uh your prodigious
workload how do you do it how do you
possibly do
this tremendous output that you do and
uh
and still have some semblance of sanity
left over well i
could ask you the same thing actually
with your
uh practicing day job at the forefront
of cosmology and also work
putting out uh very very fine books
yourself
so uh it's it's once i got liberated
from full-time teaching i was able to
write quite a bit more so
that's been the secret i think i was a
professor for 12 years and then
came to discovery and been more focused
on the research
right so i want to just read your quick
bio that i received and
um this should be familiar to many of my
listeners because they may have
encountered you already
in your debates with none other than
upcoming guest
uh dr lawrence krauss of the origins
project in the origins podcast hopefully
lawrence is coming on not too long from
now lawrence plays a not insignificant
role
in the god hypothesis i wonder did you
send him an advanced
uh copy of this book i will send it out
okay good yeah we'll get him a sign i
think he and i have dueling essays in a
journal inference
uh coming up soon oh wow okay so i
received the copy
we're the intellectual interlocutor for
sure yes that's right
and uh and the the odd couple if ever
there were one
so i received this book in the mail at
ucsd and and i and i opened it up and i
said oh steven's got a new book i didn't
know that
back in it was december 7th i know uh
because it's a day that will live in
infamy for many reasons
and i got this book and said stephen
meyer received his phd from cambridge
university in the philosophy of science
a former geophysicist and college
professor he directs the center for
science and culture
at the discovery institute in seattle he
authored the new york times best-selling
darwin state signature in the cell
sup which was selected as near as a
london times literary supplement book of
the year
it's been featured on pbs ben shapiro et
cetera center and it said professor
keating you know
uh we we um we're so pleased to present
to you
this galley copy so this is not the
original copy and it said um
uh we'd be so pleased if you'd get us
some comment on the book
uh by december 15th and you know stephen
doesn't write books by the pound but but
if he did
he'd be even more uh replete and
munificently remunerated than he is this
book is like 600 pages long so
i can't do that i you got to give me at
least eight days nine days stephen come
on
uh but uh but actually i tore through it
of course i looked up my name in it
um and uh see made sure that i was
featured prominently as
a couple of chapters befitting my my own
personal resplendence
but this book is so thoroughly
researched it really is kind of like a
mini phd in the philosophy of science
it is dense i took billions of notes on
the hard copy the i'm going to get the
audiobook version
but i want to first start off with the
question that my audience is going to
ask
why are you on this show why are you an
intelligent design
advocate on a show with a practicing
cosmologist
who professes that he is a devout
practicing
agnostic on not an infrequent basis so
what makes you and some of the work that
you do
uh what brings attention maybe even
controversy to the work that you do
well one of the things that that you
have said that i like is that you're an
agnostic who wrestles with god
you're interested in the big questions
and i am too
and i think that's a common uh interest
that we have what does science have to
say about
uh these larger metaphysical or
worldview issues if anything
i think it actually has quite a lot to
say and uh
i think there are design implications in
cosmology and physics every
bit as much as in in biology i think we
do live in a universe that has evidence
of
of design and purpose and i think that
that
means that science may have some clues
as to some of those uh the answers to
some of those big questions
so i hope that that makes some sense to
your audience but certainly i think in
our conversations
has been one of the things that has
drawn us together absolutely yeah we've
had
really um deep conversations and as you
know i'm practicing jew i'm not orthodox
devout uh orthodox but i do adhere to
the uh some of the tenants most of the
tenants in my faith
you know it's been a long time i i
haven't you know uh slept with my uh
with my
with my grandmother's uh you know
ex-husband or so you know they're all
these
mitts vote in the torah and people say i
can't keep it
i can't keep all those commandments and
i say you know did you sleep with your
with your stepmother's wife or whatever
and it's it's actually not that hard to
uh to adhere to some of these things you
know you don't
you don't have to do that much you know
find a red heifer and kill it that's
not something we have to do on a daily
basis but uh but the conversation that
we had i'll just start off by saying
the thing that worried me about um about
this book and
even you know conversing with folks like
you or william is it william lane craig
or william craig lane i always forget
william lane
you always get the sort of sense as a as
a scientist
jewish or not you know that there will
be the following progression
uh it'll start off with the column
cosmological argument that you know
anything that has a beginner
uh must have or anything that began must
have had a beginning and must perhaps
have a beginner
so cosmology the big bang the universe
had a beginning therefore
there must have been a banger as one of
my rabbis says
uh the big banger is is the uh is the
force the motive force to put the bang
in the big bang and then it will be well
because uh
god wouldn't create the universe without
some sense of purpose and design
therein it is in effect a personal god
okay so
that might follow logically from a
supposition that column is right or that
this
argument is sound um and then it will
always be and therefore
jesus and it's very difficult as a you
know practicing jew
not to deny the historicity um the
magnificent teachings of jesus the
authenticity of jesus's
life and his teachings we as you know as
jews document exquisitely
the teachings of all of our rabbis going
back thousands of years and
and jesus was of course one of the most
preeminent uh exemplars of that
tradition
um so i always find it interesting and
and a little bit
perilous to engage with christian
uh people that are scientifically
inclined to want to support
the hypothesis that jesus more than the
god hypothesis
the jesus hypothesis so can you say
something about that can you believe
can you read this book which is as i
said thoroughly documented
details the biological cosmological and
physical
implications of the evidence for design
can you accept the contents of this book
written by a christian a devout
christian
um if you're not christian and and
perhaps have no no
you know position on the act on the
legitimacy of christ as messiah
well yeah i mean you and i have
something else in common which is that
um you're kind of a christian friendly
jewish person and i'm a jewish friendly
christian person and i have a lot of
a lot of uh close colleagues in our work
of discovery who are
are jewish and um i don't think you can
settle questions
um uh specific religious questions
within especially within
the context of theism through appeals to
nature
um i think the the theologians make a
distinction between general
and special revelation and the the uh
the kind of arguments that i'm making
are based on the general revelation of
nature and i don't think they
they they settle um those differences
between jews and christians or
non-religious theists and uh muslims or
yeah
uh those those other sorts of
considerations would have to come into
play and
those conversations would have to occur
separately so
this is a book simply about well simply
it's a big topic of first the evidence
of design
uh but then it also addresses uh a
second order
not addressed before which is uh what
what what can science tell us about the
possible identity of the designing
intelligence responsible for life for
example
so that's that that that might get you
to theism i argue that it does
but uh it doesn't get you further than
that within the framework of theism
um uh or some sort of transcendent
intelligence
uh then there's there's other sorts of
questions that would require further
deliberation that can't be
i think uh settled by by appeals to
nature
and of course you know this is not a new
topic people have been kind of looking
at the confrontation
is is religion engaged in a perpetual
battle against science and and some of
those uh
come down to what uh the late great
stephen j gould called
noma non-overlapping magisterial
um support and i actually um
i've never been a huge fan of that i
always kind of find that rather bland
and
that's not to say i haven't used that
argument myself i frequently have said
you know if you pick up a book and it
says you know great the stars of the nba
and and you look through it and it's 999
pages of
the you know seven jews who have ever
made it to the nba
and there's one page about everybody
else then you would say well this is not
really an accurate title for the book
and and yet that same ratio takes place
in the bible in the old testament at
least the the testament i'm
most familiar with in that there's about
35 verses
that plausibly have to do with evolution
or the big bang or creation of the
universe
out of 35 000 verses so there's that
same ratio of one to a thousand
um and yet people want to kind of
pigeonhole it as
saying a couple of scientific things
here a couple of you know a couple of uh
of biological claims here
over there and i really feel like that's
the most that's the that's the deepest
clue that they're
it's not just that they're not
overlapping it's that they're totally
irrelevant it's like picking up a book
on quantum field theory and expecting to
find a way to raise your kids so
what is it about noma is it just because
of steven j gould's you know amazing
personality and communication of science
is there something actually there
that is more than you know than just
kind of feel good you do what you want
to do i'll do what i want to do
because i always say if god exists
you're going to act very differently
than if god doesn't exist if you know
god doesn't exist so
just tolerating it you know giving it
lip service as noma
appeals to at least in my understanding
of it um i don't find it very satisfying
is it is it legitimate in some sense
it well there's i think there's
legitimacy you know there's an old uh
saw from galileo you know the bible
tells us how to go to heaven not how the
heavens go
and that is to say much of what we call
the natural sciences
concerns questions that are religiously
neutral you know what what's the formula
for assault
what's the the uh um
so given reaction sequence or uh
the specific form of the law of gravity
or whatever but there are
uh there are questions that science
raises
that do have larger philosophical
worldview religious implications
uh what is a law of nature uh from when
from whence did the universe come uh
what caused the universe to come into
existence um
and so there i i don't adhere to know my
but i agree that there's some truth to
it there are
vast realms of science that are
religiously neutral but there are also
questions that arise in science
that are that have philosophical
worldview or religious implications
and it's at that intersection that i
think that are
some of the most interesting questions
the kind that you address on your
podcast for example
and that's what this book is about what
what do what can science tell us about
those big questions
one things i appreciate about some of
the interlocutors opposite
me um and that would be the the
uh very overt new atheist is that they
do a great job of framing some of those
big questions
so for example richard dawkins says
the universe he asserts that the
universe has exactly the properties we
should expect
if at bottom there was no purpose no
design
nothing but blind pitiless indifference
a blind pitylist and difference
just a metaphorical way of describing
what scholars call
scientific materialism the worldview of
scientific materialism that says
that there is at bottom nothing but
matter and energy the matter and energy
are the things from which everything
else comes and
the material the physical universe has
been eternal
is eternal and self-existent it doesn't
require an external cause to account for
its origin or existence
now that's a very provocative claim and
a very interesting one because what
dawkins is essentially saying is that
is that metaphysical hypotheses every
bit as much as scientific ones
might be testable by reference to
observations that we can make about the
world around us and he
asserts in fact that the metaphysical
hypothesis of scientific materialism
is testable that it comports beautifully
with what we would expect
to see if that hypothesis were true when
we go out and look at the natural world
and that's actually an excellent i use
that quote as a framing device in the
book because i want to argue just the
opposite
that there are at least three big
discoveries that we've made
about biological and cosmological
origins that are not what you'd expect
if a materialistic world view were true
but rather comport more nicely with the
expectations of theism and those three
discoveries in the book are that the
universe likely had a beginning
that it's been fine-tuned from the
beginning and subsequently and
subsequent to that for
life and that there have been large
bursts of digital information into our
biosphere that
made new new forms of life possible
and i i look at those three big
discoveries and suggest that they
comport more nicely with theism and
therefore provide
what philosophers call epistemic support
not proof but
uh evidential or epistemic support for a
theistic worldview
what level of epistemic support is
is it you know possible to say you've
achieved
a status tantamount to you know
evidentiary support uh in that you know
they say
people say oh that's just circumstantial
evidence but
you know as i understand in the american
you know juror system
there's a certain amount of of
circumstantial evidence that
upon a certain amount of it uh will
constitute enough to
at least could be dispositive in certain
legal circumstances so
at what level would there you know rise
to be the level of evidentiary support
coming from epistemological support and
maybe just define
you know both both of those uh yeah
that's that's an excellent question
especially
coming from a cosmologist i mean you
know that in your field
you're reconstructing often events that
took place billions of years ago
and you you don't have the the luxury of
being able to do
a controlled experiment or an experiment
or control laboratory conditions you
have to go back
you you reconstruct the past based on
the clues that are left behind whether
it's the cosmic background radiation or
other things
and i actually did my phd thesis on
origin of life biology
and the historical method of scientific
investigation that's used in fields like
origin of life research or
evolutionary biology or archaeology or
forensics or cosmology
there's a whole class of disciplines
that depend upon
uh long after the fact circumstantial
evidence in order to reconstruct
processes and events that took place a
long time ago
stephen j gould said that speaking of
evolutionary biology said the historical
sciences
reconstruct the facts based
on the clues that are left behind so um
so people think well that makes it a
lesser type of science well maybe
but oftentimes circumstantial evidence
can be very compelling
and it is it is in this in the
followings
uh under the following conditions
epistemologically um
often the problem with reasoning from
effects back to causes
is that there may be more than one cause
that can explain the same effect
the type of inference you use when you
reason retrodictably from effect back to
causes is known as
in logic an abductive inference now
abductive inferences can be
uh grossly underdetermined there can be
many more causes that might explain the
same effect
uh and in that case you're stuck then
circumstantial evidence isn't very
compelling
but the the historical geologists
and evolutionary biologists in the 19th
century uh
refined that method and they did so by
showing that if you compared competing
hypotheses
against often a wider ensemble of
evidence
you could narrow down the candidate
explanations and in a
in the best of cases you could infer to
a best explanation
this method known as the method of
multiple competing hypotheses
is used instinctively by people in for
example cosmology or evolutionary
biology
and it does allow us uh in in some cases
to make very definitive inferences about
the causal uh uh events in the past that
explain the
the the the ensemble of clues and
evidences that we have
in the present so circumstantial
evidence can be very powerful and it can
be dispositive
if you're in a position to make an
inference to the best explanation where
you have
after an an examination of an ensemble
of clues
only one plausible uh explanation
for the evidence at hand right and i see
this a lot in a kind of fallacy of of
insufficient evidence uh playing out
but more on a practical level in other
words you might find
a lot of scientists as union you know
mentioned in the book and
some of the most preeminent scientists
are are mentioned in this book
are are some of them are friends of mine
uh you know despite
the the the folks that i associate with
my off time
and uh and and yet they'll say things
like you know
i mean just i'll bring up sir roger
penrose he hasn't commented specifically
on this book
but uh to me but he was you know one of
the first if not the best
to really popularize this idea of the
exquisite
fine tuning or low entropy state of the
early universe
that seems in great conflict with the uh
with the theory you know of of inflation
which seems to suggest that you know
this the entropy created
during this early evolutionary you know
process in the universe of its expansion
by
you know 35 orders of magnitude and in a
microscopic fraction of a second uh that
that's
almost you know a death blow to that
theory um
and and you do mention those uh those
concerns in the book
as as you know kind of um reasons to
doubt the kind of universe from nothing
which we'll get into in just a bit
however um you know what you don't talk
so much about
is that sir roger came up with
a alternative cosmology which does away
with the evidence uh or does away with
this disposes of the
entropy challenge to the inflationary
cosmology
and it actually involves a universe with
no beginning a multiverse in time which
he calls a cyclic universe which he
calls conformal cyclic cosmology
featuring an innumerable number of uh
of of aeons eons as we would say in the
states
and uh but but i don't see much made of
that in fact i see
you know predominantly the evidence that
you put forth in the book for
a singular origin of the universe which
you know at first blush
might be considered uh you know kind of
consistent
if not proved or you know posited by the
by the bible
specifically the old testament so uh
what do you make of the fact that
you know what one cosmologist can do
another can undo in other words
we used to think the universe was
infinite it was static unchanging
uh hubble the standard lore comes along
shows even einstein was wrong
um so any any point and and now and then
later on uh folks like uh beta and gamma
came up with with the theory of the
evolution of the very earliest synthesis
of elements
then we had hoyle who's in the book and
and burbidge my
late great colleague here at ucsd coming
up with
uh quasi steady state universe and we
see this going on and on and then we had
inflation
now we have cyclic cosmology or the
bouncing cosmology of paul steinart
also in the book uh so tell me what you
know why should we trust
this science this argument that you're
making right now
when history shows time and time again
as mark twain said
their cosmology at least is rhyming that
you know you it's dangerous to say there
was a single beginning
despite all the proofs in there there's
counter proofs from everybody else so
why should we trust the cosmology which
you thoroughly
explore and explain in this book it's
really a magnificent treatment of
our current understanding but again
steven it's our current understanding
and what one cosmologist can do you know
in the past another can do better now
that's a great question um uh
uh first i i do address the the cyclic
cosmology of uh penrose first in a long
foot no and then i have extended
research notes that go with the book
they're going to be posted online and so
it's uh obviously very important to keep
current with the most current things
um and i can come back i can come back
to that in a bit
but the the the big picture broad stroke
uh answer to your question is that what
i've done is i've made an argument
for the theistic implications of modern
cosmology
that does not depend upon a specific
conclusion about
there being a beginning or not what i
have constructed is what
philosophers uh sometimes call a robust
argument meaning that
multiple multiple predicates lead to the
same conclusion
and and so i show that as best i make
the argument from a preponderance of
evidence both
from observational cosmology and from
theoretical physics uh drawing on the
singularity theorems of the 1960s and
70s which
are conditional and they're conditioned
upon general relativity and their
reasons that
we uh might not extrapolate all the way
back to the beginning if we accept
that there could be a quantum theory of
gravity in the early you know pre-plank
time
part of the universe but i also also
make the argument that that the back
extrapolation that is
being made in observational uh cosmology
that gets us to a big bang
and the um the the movement towards an
infinite curvature which is the
implication of the singularity theorems
are indicators of a beginning
and then then there's also a third line
of argument which is the
board guthful lincoln theorem that
doesn't depend upon the kind of energy
conditions that are
necessary to make the singularity
theorems work it depends only on special
relativity and basic geometric
considerations
that also implies that there was a
beginning so we have multiple lines of
evidence pointing to a beginning
but then i say but if you don't accept
that there was a beginning or if you
accept that
there might not have been a beginning
then and that in this
era of quantum gravity um we
should be exploring sort of uh quantum
accounts of the origin of the universe
then i show that those accounts of the
universe
though they've been uh promulgated by
uh sort of overt scientific materialists
they actually have latent theistic
implications
certainly idealist implications if you
want to say that the universe has come
out of a universal wave function and
then
um then you have to ask well what is the
universal wave function if you say the
laws of nature
or laws of physics explain why there is
a universe rather than nothing
uh well what are the laws of nature what
what what kind of form can they have
before there is an actual physical
universe and this is a question that was
raised by alexander valencia himself one
of the
proponents of quantum cosmology in fact
i've got
i've got the quote here it's really
provocative in the absence of space
time and energy what tablets could these
laws of nature be written upon
the laws are expressed in the form of a
of mathematical equations if the medium
of mathematics is the mind
does this mean that mind should predate
the universe
but in that account the universe comes
out of a mathematical abstraction or
a universal wave function which is the
solution to a prior mathematical
equation that wheeler dewitt equation
which is an analog to the schrodinger
equation in ordinary quantum physics
the lint can make this provocative
observation however if we're saying that
matter space time and energy come out of
essentially mathematics and mathematics
is the realm
exis is conceptual and exists in the
realm of the mind is our new account of
the origin of the universe actually
presupposing
the existence of a prior intelligence or
a mind
he doesn't answer that rhetorical
question but interestingly hawking who
is also a proponent of quantum cosmology
was sensitive to the same concern
when he said what puts fire in the
equations that gives them a universe to
describe
in our experience math by itself has no
causal powers it's causally inert
so deposit math is to posit something
that in our experience only exists in a
mind and minds of the things that do
have causal powers so have we
by circumventing one sort of
cosmological account that leads to
a theistic conclusion on one basis
namely that there was a definite
beginning or singularity
before which there was not matter space
time or energy to explain the origin of
the universe
now we have a different cosmological
account but it for different reasons
implies the prior existence of mind and
as i show in the book
even there's even some deeper logic to
that in that to get a universal wave
function
you have to solve the wheeler dewitt
equation but the wheeler-to-wood
equation is a functional
uh differential equation that has an
infinite number of solutions and can
only be solved
if there are boundary constraints placed
on that equation
and the boundary constraints are chosen
selectively by the
quantum cosmological modelers to give a
universal wave function
that includes a universe like ours which
is their condition of saying that we've
we've explained the universe so that
input of information
by the modelers i think is actually
quite significant because it suggests
that to
to get a universe like ours out the
other end you've got to put information
in
and the information is coming in the
modeling from the mind of
of of the theoretical physicists so yeah
what
what i've shown is that in a sense yeah
many roads to rome you've got you've got
different cosmological models
but they all have if you if you probe
them deeply enough they they have
implications that are not strictly
materialistic
and point in the direction of mind so
yeah wait let's go deeper in that
um i just want to remind everybody i'm
talking with dr steven meyer the
discovery institute
and author of darwin's doubt signature
in the cell
as well as the upcoming book or now
today's released just released fresh off
the presses
as they say return of the god hypothesis
we're going to talk about that word
return in a moment and because i think
it's provocative i want to ask you
to uh to visit stephen on the web on
twitter we'll have his links on the
youtube version
otherwise uh please do subscribe to this
podcast wherever you're getting it and
leave a review that's what helps us get
great guests like dr stephen meyer
and others like lawrence krauss who i
presume will come on and
present a form of rebuttal he plays not
an insignificant role
in this book and he's a controversial
character a self-declared militant
atheist
and one of the ones who i think um
although
i agree with your most recent you know
uh mentioning of the wheeler dewitt
equation which is something you know
that's not
super well known to most certainly most
practicing experimental cosmologists
and yet as an example of something which
i've encountered quite frequently
where there is sort of a teleological
imposition that's placed that you
once you have an idea uh for example the
hawking hardell no boundary proposal
which features prominently in this book
or in uh you know the ever ready in many
worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics which is another
kind of quantum mechanical
um and you know a set of equations or
framework perhaps is the best way to
describe it
that could potentially according to some
explain the features of the universe we
do observe
so when we when we look at it but the
the
challenge that i have for you is that
again you know
there's nothing that says wheeler dewitt
is is the ultimate
expression any more than there was
anybody who who said that oh hawking
hartl
um uh made this made this beautiful no
boundary proposal
what need then for a creator as you as
you mentioned in the book many times and
i have tremendous
challenges to hawking but i'm afraid
that you know you're
you will leave yourself exposed to you
know people who are
not as as friendly as i am and they'll
say things like well
no one tells you that wheeler dewitt is
correct in other words there
might not be a universal wave function
first of all um
you know how could you interact with it
how could you parameterize it
in what type of a hilbert space does it
exist while i agree with you
that the challenge to krauss and and all
um you know who popularized
lincoln's idea he wasn't the originator
of those ideas the universe from nothing
was that it presupposed the existence of
a hilbert space of a mathematical entity
of the laws of nature
and i find it very weak t as you brits
or
you're american but you spend enough
time in england to be an
honorary brit um and as they say so
it's weak to say well okay so now here's
this one it feels
like a critic will say you're cherry
picking you're saying
oh because the wheeler dewitt equation
describes the properties which a
universe must have
and all quantum mechanical systems are
undeniably subject to initial
value conditions and boundary conditions
um and
uh that that they'll say well okay so
what so wheeler do it or wrong just the
same way
that hawking and hartle are wrong so why
are you cherry picking
which physicist you choose to get your
evidence for
the uh the mind behind the universe if
again if it's eternal
just like no the stupid question that
people who created god well
god doesn't need a creator right so you
wouldn't stipulate that there has to be
a mind that creates the mind
that created the matter uh so anyway how
do you overcome that objection
that there's no saying that we now it
could be epistemologically
sufficient or could be uh parsimonious
to believe that
but there's no evidence for it we have
no no treatment no
no ability to to ascertain whether or
not the wheeler dewitt equation
is as fundamental as the schrodinger
equation in that it has predictive power
in the domain
which attempts to be magisterial over
which
right well again what i'm attempting to
do
is not to say that wheeler dewitt is
necessarily right
in fact in near the end of my treatment
with this i raised some
questions about whether this application
of quantum
the analogy that's drawn between
ordinary quantum mechanics and the
origin of the universe is
is apt at all um because there are some
dis analogies and in an ordinary quantum
mechanical system you have you have a
detector you have
something emitting uh you know electrons
or
photons you've got you have an
experimental apparatus you've got double
slits
in the quantum cosmological case you
have nothing at all
you have just the mathematics of of uh
quantum quantum physics that you apply
to try to explain the origin of the
system
rather than describing a system that
already exists
but the point that i make is that if you
take this as an
as an alternative to the
body of evidence that we have pointing
to a beginning
uh and say well there's a different way
of giving a cosmological account then
oddly that
that account also leads to a theistic
implication
um so um
the the and then in a sense what i
presented in the book is what i
i've called elsewhere a cosmological
trilemma uh
the preponderance of evidence that we
have from observational astronomy
and from developments in theoretical
physics and both special
based on both special general relativity
does point to a beginning
it's and it suggests uh that is the most
likely conclusion and
i i think there is a good argument for
theism based on
the origin of the physical universe at a
finite time in the past
um but if you don't like that conclusion
if you
opt for a different account and the the
main account that's been given
as an alternative to the beginning is
one that tries to circumvent the
beginning with
with a a a a quantum physical account of
the origin of the universe
that then also has an uh a theistic
implication
now a third approach to that is to say
well
as you mentioned uh maybe all the
possibilities that are described
by the universal wave function exist in
some
possible world the many worlds
interpretation and in a separate chapter
i show
that if you go many worlds you end up
essentially with
absurdities like boltzmann brains and
an inability to make any predictions or
explanations of a phenomena in our event
or in our in our universe you end up
having absurd
science destroying consequences so you
can't absolutely prove the existence of
god but the consequences of denying the
existence of god
as a theoretical postulate at least is
um
is a system of physics which ends up
eating its own which
ends up uh destroying for
epistemological reasons our ability to
rely
on our own reasoning capabilities about
the world around us so
at the end the choices between god and
science
or no god and no science so um
that's that's the sort of argument that
i construct in the book now there are
obviously the other thing that i i'm
critical of in the book
is the the tendency among some
theoretical physicists to create kind of
mathematical castles in the air based on
zero evidence and then say
well because i can create these mentions
that that provides a better account of
things than say what we are getting from
your field observational cosmology which
are these strong indicators of the
beginning well maybe so
but at some point you have to weigh the
epistemological weight of the
speculative mathematics against the
evidential
arguments that are evidential uh just uh
considerations that we have coming out
of observational astronomy
so i'm not and and this is where i think
it's very important to point out that
if if if the standard here is absolute
apodectic
proof of the kind you get reasoning
deductively from mathematical axioms
you don't get that you don't get that in
science you don't get that it for
a science-based argument for the
existence of god but what i'm arguing
from is the preponderance of evidence
and showing that the if the best
indications we have are of the beginning
and if the the main alternative
conclusions that we have
or the main alternative uh models that
have been proposed
as to explain away the beginning both
have theistic implications
then we have a strong argument we have
good evidence
for a theistic conclusion even if we
don't
reach the standard of proof which is
again unattainable both in science
and in science and in what you might
call natural theology science-based
arguments for god's existence
when i think about the you know kind of
approach that
atheist scientists self-declared
militant or otherwise
uh take stephen hawking and speaking of
edifices in the sky i mean no one was
better at kind of
uh slipping a slider by an unsuspecting
lay audience than stephen
because he was so charismatic he was
uh so brilliant uh and he was so
accomplished and such a brilliant writer
i only recently fit
i started reading a brief history of
time in 1988
uh when i was a teenager you know and
and i stopped reading it in 1988
and then i picked it up again in 2020
and uh and and i started reading and i
finished it and found it you know oh
these objections are trivial so i was
like congratulating my you know all it
took is becoming you know a full
professor of physics that
but he's actually a wonderful writer and
but the sophistication
needed to understand uh it's far beyond
the fact that he would say things that
such as any equation in your book cuts
the readership by half
but any mention of god doubles the
amount of readers for the book
uh and of course i i only later came to
the conclusion of what he was doing
uh was really a slant of hand and it was
um i believe
somewhat dis dishonest perhaps
intellectually to do what he did and i
can say this because
i wouldn't i wouldn't expect that you
would say it although you hint strongly
at it but you're too much of a gentleman
to mention it
and speak ill of the dead i love stephen
i am having on the first author of a
critical biography of him called hawking
hawking
sort of about the business of stephen
hawking which i call hawking
incorporated
he calls hawking hawkings charles scythe
at new york university
anyway he'll be on soon i think he his
book comes out a week or so after yours
but the the problem i have with him is
that he would use in a brief history of
time this hawking heartless cosmology
as a way to obviate the need for a
creator as he said
if god has two roles according to
stephen hawking who was not a great
theologian
although i'd point out that he thought
so much about god that he actually was
an
israelite because the word israel and
hebrew means wrestles or struggles with
god
and nobody struggled more with god than
stephen hawking and in fact the last
word
words of his book that famous book
probably one of the most popular science
books in history
sold three times more copies as you
point out than richard dawkins
blind watchmaker or the god delusion uh
it sold over 10 maybe 12 million copies
to date now
uh the lobster best sellers yeah yeah it
was and it made a whole publishing
company and a whole industry of popular
science writing which i benefit to this
day so
at the risk of you know uh of killing
the the golden goose
i i would say you know he in that book
the final three words are mind of god
in other words if this is proven to be
true uh
that uh in back in 1988 he believed that
the hawking heart of cosmology
would obviate the need for god because
god had two purposes one was to
instantiate the universe and the other
was to instantiate the laws of physics
the latter he disposed of according to
him in the grand design
another book with very strong theistic
overtones and atheistic overtones but
speaking of of
a brief history of time in that book he
goes through what i only
later really recognizes you know after
going to graduate school basically
as he was doing this mathematical trick
of transforming time in a calculational
sense
from proper time from physical time
which we enjoy and
right now and we can do experiments on
and we can observe things like
time dilation and other relativistic
effects and he converted it to this
imaginary space which is purely used
for mathematical purposes to solve
equations which otherwise cannot be
solved without these techniques
known officially as wick rotations to
the experts playing at home
and then he said well it's just a
mathematical trick and then literally
stephen a page later
it's and now we see that there's no
boundary to time and therefore there was
no need for a creator
um speaking harshly and as i assume
you know will find out when i read the
rest of hawking hawking
which talks about him as a commercial
entity uh and
uh but he was not immune to using god as
leverage to infl
to increase the uh influence of his
books and his thoughts
in that book that that that argument is
really falling on deaf ear
deaf ears and worse than that stephen
maybe you would comment on this
is that in the uh revised updated
edition 2016
he not only says that uh the more you
know there's more evidence than ever for
the no
no boundary theorem uh but there's also
evidence
more evidence for m theory and inflation
and i point out this is two years after
the bicep two affair that i play
a big role in so you do indeed yeah what
about
what about this need to to have
vindication to have proof
etc why do why do you know sort of these
uh the headlines
you know appear on page one god is dead
there's no god hawking says
and then the response to the community
falls on deaf ears
if at all on page b17 of the of the
saturday edition
that was one of the things that you
mentioned lawrence
uh claros a minute ago and i'm indebted
to him for
uh getting me into this uh whole subject
of quantum cosmology i've been i've been
studying it a bit but in prepping for a
debate i read his popular book and then
that took me to valencia and then that
got me not only i i
was fortunate enough to attend the
lecture series that
hawking did in preparation of the
release of a brief history of time when
i was a grad student in cambridge i've
been aware of this for years
but um in prepping for a debate with
krauss i ended up getting into the
technical papers on quantum cosmology
and that's reflected in
in the last three chapters of this book
and one of the things that
i was shocked to find was that this idea
of
the idea that the wic rotation that
eliminates
in a in an intermediate step in a longer
calculation the implication of
uh a singularity but only in the domain
of
imaginary time or in the complex domain
of imaginary numbers
um that that
implication that he drew from that in
the brief history of time played
absolutely no role in his technical work
with hartle
and that was something that was purely
offered for public consumption
and yet he as he pointed out in the book
itself uh
the idea of imaginary time and the
the uh the depiction of the space-time
geometry
that is possible during that
intermediate step
in the complex domain has no physical
meaning
and yet from that hawking drew a
metaphysical implication namely that
there was not a beginning to the
universe
and therefore there was no creator uh
but then he
acknowledges that when you complete the
mathematical manipulation when things
are converted back into the
real time in which we live the
singularity reemerges
and this is one of the things that was
actually also very interesting is that
the singularity is presupposed
in all of the quantum cosmological
modeling
they don't eliminate it it's only in
this popular popular work
and if if i could just cycle circle back
to the
your previous very astute question about
well you know there's always a new cosmo
cosmology how can you draw any
significant conclusion
from the whole you know body of work in
cosmology when things are constantly
changing
one of the things that's that's not
changing it's a constant
is the need to account for the
specificity of our universe as we find
it
and specificity in mathematical terms is
in a sense
um it's a rarity of condition among a
vast ensemble of possibilities
and no matter which cosmology is invoked
there is a need to there's a what's
called the
cosmic winnowing problem how do you
winnow among all those possible
ensembles of conditions and and and
possible states of affairs
how do you account for our universe
emerging out of all those mathematical
possibilities
and that problem is is ubiquitous it
cuts across the grain of different
cosmological models
you find it in multiverse cosmologies
where the multiverse is
is is invoked whether it's based on
inflationary cosmology or string theory
or the combination of the two so you cr
you construct a multiverse
uh uh cosmology to explain the
fine-tuning
but then it turns out that you need a
universe generating mechanism to
generate the new universes
in the multiverse and those generating
mechanisms themselves require prior
fine-tuning
so you have the the need for specificity
of
condition and it's left unexplained and
the same thing occurred
and this is what fascinated me in the in
the cosmological case
you can you can circumvent the beginning
problem but only at the case of a deeper
information problem you have to
you have to account for the origin of
the specificity
that is included in in in the case of
quantum cosmological models
the universal wave function so um
so some of these problems that are
necessary to account for the origin of
the universe at all why we have
something rather than nothing and
why we have a specified something rather
than all the other things that could be
are not eliminated by any cosmological
theory
and and instead continue to beg the same
types of questions
questions about the origin of
specificity of information where
in our experience we know of only one
cause for the origin of information for
the origin of specificity in that sense
or the origin of fine-tuning and that
that that causes a mind
so there's a kind of incorrigibility of
the same type of problems in all the
cosmological models
and that's that's that's what i meant
earlier when i was referring to a kind
of the
what i done in the book was construct a
robust argument one that was not
dependent
on one model versus another but rather
upon
the need to solve certain basic classes
of problems that are only solved in our
experience by the
by the postulation of of mind or
intelligence
i'm talking with dr stephen meyer the
discovery institute
author of darwin's doubt signature in
the cell
and the latest book return of the god
hypothesis
let's get to that title word return
because you know for many of us we never
started off with a god hypothesis
and it's often made a great deal of and
you talk about this in the book the god
of the gaps
and how even the great isaac newton who
you know folks like krauss disparage
you know as a as a wanton torturer of
counterfeiters
and even i've been known to poke fun at
his alchemic alchemical
explorations as well of course he was a
you know phenomenal scientist but you
know it's often been said that he was
able to patch certain holes in the
theory of universal gravitation
by only invoking uh theories of
of god's intervention or angels
supporting
matter distribution now i heard that in
the context
of the static universe the apparent
static universe
i hadn't actually until you brought to
my attention this kind of offhand
comments by
neil degrasse tyson and others of you
know this this failure and that you know
that of how newton stymied scientific
progress because of this can you say
something about the
invalidity of that actually the the lack
of scientific
uh curiosity or or good scientific
practice and just
accepting these folklore table tales
about isaac newton
and his supposed appeals to the god of
the gaps
it's amazing brian i've heard this this
story about
newton invoking either the action of
angels or the direct action of the deity
to remedy an insufficiency in his laws
of gravitation because
as he examined the solar system he saw
that there were certain
points when you'd get the outer planets
in conjunction that would make the whole
thing stable and at that point he would
he would uh postulate the direct
uh and specific idiosyncratic action of
god
to to stabilize things and then the
solar system could continue to work
according to the laws that he had
otherwise
discovered um i wouldn't i've been
suspicious of this for a long time
because
uh when i was in grad school my uh
one of my phd examiners in a tutorial
said if you miss
newton's theism you've missed everything
he was he was devoutly
religious but he was also what the whole
point of the principia
was that he was he was arguing that the
mathematical harmony of the universe the
mathematical principles that were
evident
in the universe displayed the handiwork
of god
so to say that the mathemati the the
mathematical laws were insufficient and
that they required episodic
interventions and interposing of divine
will
to remedy uh uh instabilities in the
system was contrary to
his whole program of research so i was
always suspicious of this story
and so i decided to look into it myself
i got into the principia
and lo and behold he actually argues
that the planetary system
he he he does point out that there are
these perturbations that that arise from
time to time as the planets
the outer planets get into uh certain
alignments
but he says doesn't matter the the
system as a whole
is is stable on the order of millions of
years
uh for you know he says for vast eons of
time and he never
posits a an episodic intervention of the
deity to
to remedy the irregularities
irregularity in the in the planetary
system that a real
an irregularity that would not be
captured by his his law of gravity
so it's just a myth um but to your
earlier question about the word return
the book the title of the book invites
um interest in a story and the story is
that
quite contrary to the depiction
of the relationship between science and
religion that's offered
by for example contemporary new atheists
or
by late 19th century historians
um historians of science now recognize
that uh theistic concepts specifically
judeo-christian
concepts that were part of the milieu of
western europe from roughly 1300 to 1700
1750
were crucial to the rise of modern
science in particular
the concept of lawful order the idea
that there are three metaphors that are
commonly used and you find them in the
writings of
kepler and galileo and boyle and newton
metaphors like the laws of nature
or nature perceived as a clock
or a great mechanism or the book of
nature all of these are
metaphors of theological origins there's
a there are laws of nature because
there's a law giver there's a sustaining
uh the the the deity is understood to be
sustaining the regularities that we see
he's not an explanation for irregularity
but a deeper explanation for why
nature is uniform in the way that makes
science possible another key concept
that came out of this period of the
scientific revolution
was a concept of intelligibility that uh
the early
natural philosophers mechanical
philosophers people would say would call
scientists
believe they could study nature and and
that nature would have would reveal its
secrets
because there was a built in rationality
or design
in nature that was the product of the
divine mind
the same mind that had endowed in us
rationality so there was a principle of
correspondence there was rationality
built into the universe
and we being rational creators made in
the image of the rational creator
who had made the universe that way could
understand the order and design that
he'd put into it and thus kepler spoke
about
the high calling of the scientists was
to think god's thoughts after him
so these theological concepts and are
were crucial to the the rise of modern
science the
development of systematic methods for
studying nature and that perspective
uh i think was largely lost in the late
19th century early 20th century the
story of the book
is the story of discoveries that i think
should and are beginning to rightfully
bring that perspective back
so there's a kind of art to the story
that theistic ideas
helped inspire science a lot of that
theistic
perspective was lost in the late 19th
century with with figures like huxley
and darwin and in other fields marx and
freud
but much of that is now beginning to
come back as scientists i think are
again opening their minds to the idea
that there could be purpose and design
in the universe after all
is it a valid argument to say that
uh an absence of understanding of how
a deity could instantiate these
processes
is a strike against the god hypothesis
in the following sense so
uh let's stipulate that the universe
began
either you know in a finely you know
tuned initial condition
in the inflationary cosmology or in the
cyclical episodic cosmologies of
of of penrose of steinhardt of turok and
many others
uh let's just stipulate the the universe
emerges and that with the proper
characteristics and then uh the universe
is kind of a boring place
uh for hundreds of thousands of years uh
and even at that time when
my bread and butter my bread was
buttered uh so to speak when the cosmic
microwave background is produced the
formation of
of hydrogen still not much happens uh
for another 400 million years
when galaxies begin to form and then and
then you know there is a surface of
galaxies in the observable universe we
have no evidence for life or anything
and any other
planet in our solar system uh even
let alone in other solar systems in our
galaxy let alone in other
galaxies in the current time in our
present universe
let alone in the past or the future of
our current observable universe but
let's just say
the universe is pretty boring uh and
then if you're just kind of as i like to
do
let's talk about me uh just focus on the
earth nothing much happens the earth you
know
coalesces out of a protoplanetary disk a
bunch of dust
comes together billions of years go by
um
yeah and then uh all of a sudden you
know some molecules
come out of the primordial soup uh
perhaps uh you know with information
i'll even stipulate there's information
there uh that was cell
cellular digital information in the form
of the genetic code
um all this playing out by the laws of
physics which you argue
are very finely tuned i should point out
there's a colleague my
good colleague fred adams at the
university of michigan who claims that
the actual the evidence for fine tuning
in cosmology is not quite as
as stringent as as made out and we'll
talk about that some other time
because i think it's a detailed
especially as it pertains to this
rambling question i'm asking
so the universe is pretty darn boring
for you know for about nine billion
years until the earth forms
then the earth forms and again if we're
the pinnacle of creation if we are the
you know the planet which as you believe
will host the messiah i believe the
messiah you know will
you believe he'll come back i believe uh
he's yet to come but
those are the last time yeah yeah
exactly you know we could ask him when
he comes as avi loeb my friend uh
quoting uh ellie wiesel has said
um you know when he comes we'll ask him
is this your second time or your first
and then we'll finally know
uh sort it out yeah yeah so so this is
the pinnacle of creativity
but how does god interact in your view
as a as a philosopher etc very
very by the way to the audience out
there i might be rambling but the book
is not
uh the book is as deep in cosmology i
mean we're talking about wick rotations
complex planes
couchy integrals and then is equally
kind of fluid and maybe even more so
conversant with the biological
implications because that was your
really your domain expertise in graduate
school but anyway
god is kind of patient right uh and he's
waiting
and then uh and then all of a sudden the
code becomes active
and then we've only had civilization for
the past few hundred thousand years i
don't think you deny evolution obviously
but you believe it's directed by by a
mind uh
and and even the laws of physics are
tuned and that requires
a mind to tune but i want to ask you
how does the deity interact in other
words he was fine-tuning 14 billion
years ago nearly
and then but the pinnacle of what he's
waiting for comes about in the last
hundred thousand years so let's
round up these are big numbers it's
basically the entirety of the universe
for the laws to actually matter uh in
other words
you know forget about dinosaurs we i
don't really care about that
if we are the pinnacle we're the only
entity with mind that is conscious that
is conscious as homo sapiens means we
are conscious of our existence and that
we
are existing therefore we know we're
going to die
now we're the only animals we're the
only creatures that can do that so with
a pinnacle
why would god do it in this way um you
know why
why how would he do it because i think
it's fair to ask
how you know is he in a laboratory is he
is he
experimenting if so you know how does it
get instantiated
the mind is it just like this roll the
dice it came up
so finely tuned because he's omniscient
omnipotent and everything else
that he knew eventually there'd be a you
and me in the zoom call
that we could chat on in other words how
is the mind
able to account for water yeah for the
teleological purpose that we should
exist
let me speak first about the time
question because i have i have uh you
know friends
to my uh friends to my right if you will
who are uh uh old to a young earth
creationist view and they're often
troubled by the great amounts of time
that have
elapsed from the beginning of the
universe to the first appearance of life
on earth
and i think you could ask that question
coming from
the opposite perspective but to me i
think the
the great expanse of space the great
expanse of time that
that you know we have lots lots of
galaxies that don't seem to give any
evidence of life lots of planets that
uh uh don't seem to have the right
conditions
uh our planet does seem to be very
privileged as one of my uh my colleagues
put it in the book privileged planet
uh but to me it speaks of a kind of
divine extravagance that
the whole great big universe with 13.8
billion years of time that preceded us
was leading up to a teleological
endpoint
so i don't find that the the amount of
time that's transpired from the
beginning until the appearance of life
on earth
troubling uh but there's a uh
there were concepts theological concepts
that existed
prior to any of this discussion that i
think were helpful and they were part of
the scientific revolution that
i did that um
there were two powers of god that were
relevant to understanding nature one was
called the
potency ordinata the ordinary power of
god
which was posited as the explanation for
the regularities that we see in nature
that god's
hand was was for the most part hidden in
that but yet god was behind the
the regularities what we call the law
the laws of nature are a mode of divine
action
and then theologians also spoke of
something they called the potentia
uh uh absolutely or the fiat power of
god where god
was capable on occasion of acting as an
agent within the orderly concourse of
nature that he otherwise sustained and
upheld and so uh i think we have
evidence of both powers of god in our
physical cosmos and certainly the
fine-tuning of the initial conditions of
the universe and
and there i i also i know about fred
adams and i also know um
if you've looked at the book fortunate
universe by
um luke barnes and uh
his uh cambridge grads supervisor whose
name is slipping my mind
the gerund lewis yeah they were guests
yeah lewis yeah yeah yeah yeah they've
you know the terrific
pairing there with a theist and a
materialist discussing the fine-tuning
but
they they they argue that adam's
position is really an outlier
at the end of the book say whether
you're a materialist or a theist here's
a great list of
fantastic physicists who all see the
fine-tuning was a real thing
and it has to be explained one way or
another whether by a multiverse or by
theistic design whether by many
universes or one god
um but in any case the point is
i think in the fine-tuning and i and for
me in the origin of life
and the origin of the digital code i
think we see evidence of discrete
intelligent action everything we know
from experience
shows that information especially in a
digital or alphabetic form and that's
what we find at the foundation of life
in dna and rna i mean this should this
is a stop press
moment in the history of biology that
when we discover that
you know the secret to heredity the
secret to how proteins are built
is actually a complex information
storage transmission and processing
system that's run by
literally digital code that is being
expressed in
accord with an independent symbol
convention that we now call the genetic
code
this is an extraordinary discovery and
yet every day men and women get together
and do it for free
yeah yeah yeah well exactly exactly so
uh you know where did the information
come from that problem
has stymied origin of life research this
is what
i did my phd on it's what the book
signature in the cell was all about
uh even uh uh new atheists as prominent
as richard dawkins
have acknowledged that we have no idea
from an evolutionary point of view
how life first originated from simple uh
non-living chemicals although as darwin
himself pointed out you know this better
than anybody but
he said it's no objection to speak of
the origin of life as not being
understood within the theory of
evolution
one might as well criticize the origin
of matter
and you know i'd like to point out we
understand the origin of matter now but
but is that a god of the yeah is that a
god of the gaps argument type of
argument
i think on darwin's part it's more
materialism of the gaps
we don't understand the origin of matter
so why should we have to come up with an
explanation for the origin of life
uh in in fact we don't understand the
origin we still don't understand the
origin of either from a materialistic
point of view
but as for the origin of information we
have a wealth of experience
as to what causes information to arise
the great information theorist henry
quassler who was one of the first
information theorists to apply that the
information sciences to an analysis of
molecular biology says that in our
experience he says
information habitually rises from
conscious activity
and we know this from and this is part
of what we know and should be
helping to inform us as we think about
the origin of information in a
biological context
whenever we see information whether it's
in computer code
or in a hieroglyphic inscription or a
paragraph in a book
or information that's embedded in a
radio signal and we trace it back to its
source
we always come to a mind not a material
process so when
the discovery of information the
foundation of life
in every living cell including the very
simple simplest ones
uh i think is is evidence of of the
activity of a mind of intelligence
and uh in fact it's this this connection
between
information and intelligence is
presupposed in
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence they're looking for
information
embedded in radio signals and if they
find it they're gonna they're gonna
conclude that
that it has an intelligent source from
another another galaxy or planet or
something
so um i i think to get back to the
broader question you asked
i think we have evidence of of um
a discrete divine action at the
beginning of the universe
and very possibly after that especially
with the
the or the the origin of the information
necessary
to get life going in the first place
yeah and you see this also i won't
belabor the point but the simulation
hypothesis is also a presupposition
which i think ultimately you know it's a
it's a it's a design theory it's a
design theory design yeah and it brings
up all sorts of interesting you know
theological questions of theodicy of the
simulators you know
would they create evil but but again you
know i've had this argument from
the left uh i say with sean carroll you
know who said that you know god is not a
good theory he
so i've asked him point blank you know
what are the odds of the multiverse is a
true
explanation for the origin of the laws
of nature in our physical universe and
he says 50 50.
and i said what are the odds of god's
existence and he says less than
one percent so he won't rule it out
obviously but he'll say things like well
um can you envision a simpler universe
can you envision a simpler universe
that could exist be via occam's razor if
you like which which i often point out
you know
uh is more like a hatchet than a razor
is employed by most people
but nevertheless having uh you know a
simpler universe he would posit
you know an empty hilbert space to which
i'll say well who creates the hilbert
space and
you know and he really doesn't have a
good example he'll say things oh come on
you know where does that come
but it is true they're they're you know
i i think the
and he's he's i would say he he i would
say is
not you know as a pacifist atheist and
that he's he's not interested in
converting people uh to to atheism as as
dawkins or
or kraus might openly suggest they are
and yet he'll say things like well what
is the purpose of the hubble deep field
galaxy you know 65 252
over there on the left uh you know the
cosmic wallpaper as we call it
what's the purpose of that galaxy what's
the purpose of
uh of you know the 40th excited state of
xenon
uh what is the purpose of cp violation
in cobalt 60 you know why are these
things exist um
is it you know god's just having fun i
mean extravagance is one thing but you
know as we know
there's no information without energy
there's no creation of
of order you know without destruction
reduction of entropy and that requires
energy
so you know is it just the prophecy is
it
god's showing off you mentioned before
it's sort of like almost like a flourish
uh the magnificence of it all but it
would seem very profligate and so
what what is it or i think you might
answer
but i should let you answer but uh but
we don't know
in other words we can't know why god
would do it but what would be the
purpose of
wasting i mean it's like lawns in the
western hemisphere
were created you know by as a byproduct
of royalty
demonstrating that they didn't need to
use their their their
their agricultural resources to grow
food
it was meant to show resplendent
abundance
in their creation so what is the purpose
of cobalt 60's parity violation what is
the purpose of xenon's 40th resonance
what is the purpose of that galaxy over
there
in a universe with a mind it would seem
quite wasteful
well our approach is not to try to
assign a purpose to everything that we
see in the nature
in nature but rather to detect action of
intelligence where the evidence the
distinctive hallmarks of intelligence
are present um as to the rest
maybe it is cosmic wallpaper but the
hubble deep field's an awfully beautiful
piece of wallpaper i mean
it's really you know so yeah i i pointed
out that sean you know
i have a colleague who studies that
galaxy okay i love i have i have a
powerpoint i do on
on your field on cosmology i have a
beautiful picture of the hubble deep
field i think it's gorgeous you know
um there is extravagant beauty in in in
the universe and
but our my work
the work of other people who work on
intelligent design is not trying to
assign a purpose to every last piece of
the universe but rather
to detect activity of intelligence where
it is to be found
and i think it is certainly found in the
origin of life it's certainly found in
the fine-tuning
it's certainly found i think at the
beginning of the universe so
um so rather than uh say
how did god do it in that sense we're
trying to detect
that there was a mind behind it and then
in this book what i do
is is ask the question well what is the
most likely identity of a dis
of the designing mind that is revealed
by these
these features of the universe that
display distinctive hallmarks of mind
and that's where i say i i don't think
it's a space alien
i don't think it's even just a deistic
creator when you look at
the you know dawkins actually in a film
uh several years ago was interviewed by
ben stein and he he said ben stein asked
him about the problem of the origin of
the first life and dawkins acknowledged
that
there isn't an adequate materialistic
evolutionary explanation for for same
and he said you know it might be that
there's a signature but this is dawkins
speaking there might be that there's a
signature of intelligence in the cell
in in which case it would have had to
have come from
another uh an alien intelligence that
itself was evolved by
undirected natural pan [ __ ] yeah
that's that's unsatisfying in this in
in in two respects uh and i argue
against this in the book is it
it was taking it let's take it seriously
as a metaphysical hypothe
hypothesis first it pushes the question
of the ultimate origin
back one generation out into space
without answering it
um and it leaves it unanswered whereas
the theory of intelligent design
the only cause does generate information
and that is mind
but secondly any intelligence within the
cosmos
cannot account for the evidence of
design that precedes it in the
fine-tuning of the laws and constants of
physics and the
initial conditions of the universe that
that
evidence of design points in a
transcendent direction something beyond
the universe
or to a transcendent multiverse but i
have
uh uh reasons that i lay out in the book
for preferring
a theistic design hypothesis is an
explanation for the fine-tuning
over and against the multiverse in
particular that the multiverse requires
universe generating mechanisms
which themselves require prior
unexplained fine-tuning so the
fine-tuning never gets ultimately
explained by the multiverse hypothesis
and yet there is one type of explanation
that accounts for finely tuned systems
in our experience whether they're french
recipes or
exquisitely crafted pieces of machinery
or digital code
uh and that is again what we mean by
fine-tuning is a small probability
system
uh that achieves an overall function a
discernible function
and when those two things are conjoined
we we talked about that as fine-tuning
and we also know in experience that that
those types of systems arise from mind
so i think although i think i think
there are reasons to prefer
theistic design over the multiverse i
don't think it's 50 50 for one and zero
for the other
i think there's reasons to prefer one
well to be fair to sean he said one
percent or less so he didn't quite say
zero he's too smart to say
zero right to be fair to sean carroll
for another reason i
i very much appreciate his work because
unlike some of the
really ardent defenders of of scientific
materialism
who take it as axiomatic and take anyone
who disagrees is
as ignoble and ill-informed
uh carol is very clear that scientific
naturalism or materialism
is itself a metaphysical hypothesis it's
a world view that needs to be defended
and i i appreciate him for that reason
because he puts it on the table and says
all right let's look at it
what's the evidence for and against he
makes a case and with such a person you
can have a really
a very constructive conversation yeah
he's a genuine
uh intellectual and somebody that i have
great respect for he's also a phenomenal
scientist
and a yes mentor and uh and he endorsed
my book so i can't say anything so you
have
you can only say good things and you you
you gave me a nice endorsement so
yeah although with endorsements you know
endorsements are kind of funny because
you know because of the zero-sum nature
of reading books yeah i can't read your
book and read my book or a customer can
you know so it's kind of dangerous right
you don't want to be too glowing in the
praise of another's work now your
book is really phenomenal as i say you
may not agree with everything
but you'll have your work cut out for
you and uh and for me
you come away sharpened uh for for the
better
from this debate i want to push back a
little bit on the mind and the code
anyone who's ever been to the dmv and
picked up a license plate you know i
take a license plate the other day
uh for uh for my wife's car getting
renewals
6zq you know txy4
wow that's really improbable i mean to
find that i was
you know that license plate is extremely
improbable you know
one in a billion chance uh of trillions
of chances actually with all the letter
combinations it could be
uh and yeah i got that very one and
obviously there's no mind you know
behind that it might have been a random
number generator and of course random
processes can be created
randomly truly by the radioactive decay
which doesn't require a mind unless you
want to go to really prima facie causes
uh but let's just restrict it to
naturalistic explanation
and yet there's no real design yes maybe
it was didn't have a thousand letter
sequence but but it wasn't and and
but it wasn't really wasteful it wasn't
using you know uh hieroglyphics
it wasn't you know just demonstrating
the the power of the mind
so i want to ask you you know at some
level
do you think it's possible to derive
uh not just a non-deistic god but a
personal judeo-christian god
from these arguments that you make in
this book or from
intelligent design generally speaking
that advocate for a single god as
atheists will say is
in the cute kind of uh you know uh tried
and true way
they'll say i'm i'm i'm not only a
monotheist i actually believe in even
fewer gods than you stephen
i believe in no gods uh so in the sense
can you can can intelligent design uh
follow down a path that will lead to a
personal god
in the sense of god who cares about the
of perhaps
interacting with the laws of nature
maybe not for brian keating
but for jesus christ in your opinion uh
you know and so forth a god who
intervenes personally to achieve a a set
of of goals or commandments
uh as in the ten commandments that we
adhere to um
can you get from id to you know a.d
uh in that in a direct path or is it as
difficult as proving god's existence to
be
real um well there's actually two
questions in your in your questions let
me take the first one about
the detection of design the detection of
false positives with design
yeah a design inference um the
work that my colleague william dempsky
has done in his book the design
inference shows that
yeah it's absolutely possible uh to
get a few you know a few letters or a
few
things to arise that look as though
they're designed
and the question is do you have the
probabilistic resources to
explain such things by chance and often
you do but there also becomes points
where there's
you're beyond the reach of chance and
this has been widely recognized by
origin of life researchers themselves
there's a
great quote from the scottish biochemist
karen smith where he says you know a few
uh
you can easily by chance generate a few
short words
cat ran uh you know i used to do this
with my students reaching the scrabble
bag
and pick out pick out letters and
occasionally
they would you know in in a
demonstration in class they'd get the
word cat
or ran or something like that but i was
attempting to show that chance is not an
adequate explanation for the origin of
the amount of information you would need
to build
one protein let alone a full living cell
and so i would always win the
demonstration
when the argument in the demonstration
by continuing to allow them to pull
letters out
because as karen smith pointed out if
you need a vast amount of information as
the amount of organization or
information
required increases chance becomes
increasingly implausible and
demski has shown that there's an
absolute cut off where you exceed what
he calls the probabilistic resources of
the universe
and so in my in both signature in the
cell and i reprise this
argument a bit in return of the god
hypothesis
i show that there's actually some
sophisticated second order probabilistic
reasoning that allows you to eliminate
the chance hypothesis if you have a
a a very highly specified thing that
you're seeking through a random search
and you're only able to sample a small
uh miniscule proportion of the total
in this case sequences that are relevant
um
in the time available since the
beginning of the universe till now
counting every interaction of elementary
particles
as as an event you can show that there
aren't enough events since the beginning
of the universe to sample more than
in calculation i made more than 10 10
trillion trillionth of the total
relevant sequences in
searching for one modest protein
in that case you can eliminate the
chance hypothesis it's more likely than
not the chance will be
false it's overwhelmingly more likely
than not that a random search will fail
in which case it's overwhelmingly more
likely that the chance hypothesis is
false and true
so there are there there are ways of
guarding against the kind of false
positive
inferences to design that you were just
describing with the license plate
illustration um as to the second
question of how you get from an
inference to um design simplicitor or to
a generic intelligence which is as far
as i take the argument in my first two
books
in darwin's doubt and signature in the
cell how you get from
a generic designer to a designer that
has the attributes
of a god
that would be recognizable to theists
well that that is the argument of the
new book
and what i do there is broaden the the
using the method of inference to the
best explanation or multiple competing
hypotheses
that i described earlier in in our
discussion
i broadened the ensemble of relevant
evidence from just the biological
evidence the evidence of design we have
long after the beginning of the universe
to look at the evidence that we have
either from the beginning of the
universe or soon after the laws of
physical chemistry are taking shape
and showing that that that you have
evidence of design prior to the origin
of any possible
imminent intelligence no space alien
could be responsible for the
fine-tuning of the initial conditions of
the universe of the laws and concepts of
physics
upon which its very existence depends
and so
that candidate designer isn't very good
in which case
you're looking at something that is is
pointing beyond the universe
uh and and then i think you start to to
look at evidence for
transcendent intelligence but also we
have evidence of design
long after the beginning so you i think
when you take the
ensemble of evidences jointly you have
evidence
for both an active intelligence
but one which is transcendent and those
two two uh
uh attributes jointly i think uh give
you
attributes that we uniquely associate
with with the deity
oh that's fascinating stephen you know i
love talking to you i could talk to you
all day
i would be upgraded and possibly uh
physically abused by
uh many people more intelligent than me
aka my wife
if i don't go and pick up one of my
children i gotta pick up some kids
yeah that's right uh but i do wanna put
a pin in some of these conversations
because i
i do think it would be great to have
more debates and discussions with you
about um about these ultimate issues in
in life and existence i think there's so
much fun i think when you take out the
hostility of the militant atheist
and and you do so with uh
with with love and with true interest in
understanding the other's point of view
i find your work fascinating again as i
said in my in my blurb
you might not agree with everything but
the but the point being this is
these are the the issues that make life
worth thinking about and living
and understanding because not just in
the pascal's wager sense of things i
think
that if you don't examine these things
uh it's sort of
you're you're you're not making use of
the full computational power it's like
buying an iphone
and oh it has a camera i don't need that
uh oh it can browse the internet
i'm just having it you know i just have
it for uh for the notes app uh but but
stephen
i i love talking with you i love meeting
you in person uh
about three weeks ago uh but now i want
to
ask you if you are willing to go into
the impossible
and answer the final three questions
that i ask
all my treasured guests who come on the
into the impossible podcast
and to hear steven's answer i learned
this trick from our mutual friend ben
shapiro to hear steven's answer you're
gonna need to subscribe
uh to my mailing list which you get at
brianketing.com steven is a subscriber
as are many of my guests so by the way
if you want to be in great company with
the
wonderful brilliant nine nobel prize
winners who have been on the show
uh billionaires brainiacs ordinary
people like you and me
uh please uh subscribe briankeating.com
and you'll get a link
to the answers that stephen will provide
to the thrilling three so
if you're not gonna listen to that or
subscribe signing off enjoy the rest of
the universe but for now those
subscribers now stay tuned
for stephen's answers to the thrilling
three you can get a link to it
down here or to my mailing list uh right
there
uh stephen i want to thank you so much
for going into the impossible i wish you
wish you the success and blessing and
happiness that you
are so richly deserving them and i hope
we'll meet again for more of these
stimulating
stimulating impossible conversations and
i hope it won't take 14 billion years of
evolution and design for us to come
together again
fantastic these conversations are often
impossible because of that
underlying hostility that we talked
about between different groups but i
think
uh we've made it possible this morning
thanks to a great question so
thanks for having me on any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you